welcome back we're here with dog rescue
advocate victoria lilly schaefer
that's right
victoria um your advocacy and compassion
for rescue dogs is so inspiring that we
want to honor your work and we wanted to
spread the love today so carrie and her
boyfriend jacob are here today and they
want to rescue a dog
hi carrie and jacob how are you guys
how are you excited this is so exciting
it's so exciting so exciting
um why do you want to adopt now at this
moment of your life sure uh so we i
think been dating for about three and a
half years and i think ever since month
six we were like we need to have a dog
together and we finally found a place
where we felt like we could do that and
give it a loving home
and so we thought this year no better
place or time to do it than christmas
time and so it's our gift to each other
this year oh my
god ow
so excited
oh my god my heart i'm not kidding it's
like the best thing you will ever do is
adopt a puppy
i'm just so excited for your new life
are you ready to make it official so
ready oh my god okay
um let's meet uh your new dog i mean you
know i victoria i feel like you should
be doing the introduction this is all
you
ozzy come out
guys
[Applause]
the two of us look at this
it's meant to be it's kismet
oh my goodness oh he's so sweet
i know it's so much all these people
what a show
victoria were you like okay let me find
the cutest puppy on planet earth i mean
it definitely helps if we're trying to
promote adoption here today it certainly
does you chose the best ambassador i've
ever seen
what do you guys think he's just
precious so precious
look at some tears i know
he's definitely rambunctious so you know
just be patient with him okay well paul
i'm so happy to see you
it's been a long time let me thank you
for having victoria and me on the show
today and and
rue yes
this is just so great for my daughter
yeah you guys congratulations
and if carrie and jacob maybe need a
little tip advice sort of some guidance
along the way can we connect you and
also we want to go on this journey with
you and see how everything is going
we would love that absolutely
it takes a village we'll build a
community
and i can't wait to see ozzy grow up
that's the cutest job i've ever seen in
my life
but i i loved sharing a life with you i
think i was on like 19 times and i just
also as a viewer and as someone who
loves you and david so much i just thank
you for all the goodness well uh you
were david letterman's favorite guest
and it was
because
as you always delivered when you came on
you were just funny and entertaining and
charming and exactly what what any uh
talk show host would want and it's so
congratulations on your show
i love what you've done with the place
all the little touches are beautiful and
what a dog friendly every as soon as you
get here they say here we'll give you a
drew caller for your dog and everybody
has them douglas isn't it and victoria
was just blown away i will say that you
know i like you and david what you put
out into the world what you created
together and how you took care of all of
us and entertained us and just
put us to bed feeling like life was okay
we had done a good job it was time for
us to
enjoy
ourselves we had made it through the day
and
i mean
what an amazing extraordinary empire
that the both of you built thank you so
much but the thing is that you are oh
that's nice
and
my wife and i watch you in the mornings
really yes and we
you know you are taking over from where
david and i left off and you now start
people's day with with a positive
energy that means so much coming from
you i've spent so many
incredible memorable moments of my life
whether it was as a viewer learning you
know
what great television was what great
comedy was what interesting
conversations were
and i mean and then i certainly had some
crazy memories paul i was outer body on
that particular birthday
i had no
idea what i was doing do you remember
anything about it because i had a full
blackout like will ferrell in old school
when he's at the debate against james
carville and he's like i just blacked
out what happened
i i i there was no plan for that moment
what was going on on your side
i
remember every single detail it was the
best present you could have given him
she flashed she flashed david
and i was watching from i saw it from
the side and let me tell you
i'll never forget it it's fantastic one
of those great memories it was one of
those that's why i'm going to stand up
here right now
i wouldn't do that dave came here for my
birthday i saw it i know it was great
and i got up on that desk and and then i
found out it was a miracle it's glass
and i don't know how by the way that
would have been so my life
that would have been a different moment
may i ask you as now the appropriate
woman who's afraid you are two daughters
who literally says to my daughters like
if you even think you're wearing a crop
top you're out of your mind um but i
mean what's it like to see your own
daughter
doing this extraordinary work
victoria has always made me nothing but
proud
um and this is you know i she had to
sort of overcome a little bit of
resistance from from here there were
some hurdles i had to just and yes like
every time we would go on vacation she
would say well let's let's just uh get
rent bikes and drive over to the pet
store and just visit the puppies you
know that's how she started
i'm fine to
visit the puppies and then she talking
about how cute they are and everything
and her little brother will you know the
two of them about this high in there
with the puppies and it was just little
by little chipping away and finally
we broke down and our two dogs whom we
missed very much jake and riley when
they grew up we were an actual dog
family and victoria
is an expert
she knows everything there is to know
about dogs or their their mental health
their physical health
she teaches me something every day and
um and of course there's a lot of
puppies on him yeah as well sometimes we
visit her for christmas i got 14
dogs here now what you know well 10
puppies and the mother that's 11 and my
three
victoria what was the best advice your
dad ever gave you may i ask
oh my goodness
i would say
it was to follow your dreams
and this is my dream right here to
promote adoption and rescue and have a
bunch of dogs um and i'm just so happy
to do it so
that would probably be it she never
really wanted to wear a crop top
all right
good fine with that yeah the heels
sometimes got a little high three four
inches you know but she's a small person
she needs yeah i need something
yeah it's just funny how much no matter
what journey that you've been on in life
or how you grew up or what your parents
were like or what your circumstances i
have grown up into
a 47 almost year old woman who really
believes that being a good girl is where
it's at and it's an honor and a pleasure
to be a parent now of two girls and to
have gathered the information
um about humor affection
you know all of it and to be so proud to
have the karma to have this chance to
raise girls
we sort of grew up with you and we're
proud of you and now you know here you
are
uh a woman and uh i had no idea you were
you look half your age
yeah you're the whole package and i i
can't thank you enough for having us
well you're a great dad the best man
i'm so happy to have grown up with and
around you and to hear a father-daughter
story it's just so inspiring we all live
for it and what you are doing with your
organization thank you
it's so meaningful and we can't wait to
be a part of your journey and promote
your beautiful company that's going to
bring so much joy
and life change to people in all the
right ways so victoria and paul thank
you so much and don't forget pop culture
[Applause]
and the importance of adopting a dog is
available now and a special thanks to
rescue city in new york city for helping
make this amazing connection happen
aussie we'll be right back
[Music]